Trascrizione: Moira De Giorgi
Revisore: Susanna Brioschi
Io ricordo quand'ero ragazzino
ogni tanto si giocava al telefono.
Si prendevano due coppette vuote
di gelato, si metteva un filo in mezzo,
uno parlava e l'altro ascoltava,
poi quelli più avventurosi
provavano ad aggiungere coppette,
ad aggiungere fili,
e si scopriva che se tu legavi il filo
in un certo punto, l'altro sentiva,
e se lo legavi in un altro, non sentiva,
se mettevi un certo numero
di coppette funzionava,
se ne mettevi un numero diverso
non funzionava.
Soltanto tanti anni dopo, quando
ho cominciato a capire le onde,
quando mi hanno parlato di segmento aureo
e di serie di Fibonacci,
ho capito quelle cose,
ma allora era pura magia.
Erano delle comunicazioni fatte in casa,
chiaramente arrivavano soltanto
in un certo ambito.
Non erano come le telecomunicazioni
di oggi che raggiungono
i quattro angoli del mondo, un mondo
che è rotondo e non ha angoli.
Quindi capite anche la complessità
di fare queste cose, no?
In generale non ce ne accorgiamo
che sono complicate
perché sono nascoste, non le vediamo,
ma se soltanto andassimo
a passeggiare per le strade di Hanoi
o qualche paese in Sud America o Africa,
vedremmo delle matasse
di fili impressionanti,
allora ti viene in mente e dici:
"Cribbio, ci sono queste infrastrutture,
guarda come sono complicate!"
E non solo!
Capiresti anche che aggiustare queste
cose deve essere una cosa complicatissima.
E guardate questo signore
che si arrampica in mezzo a questi fili
e credo debba trovare quello giusto per
riuscire a fare le cose che deve fare.
Eppure ci sono delle reti
che sono molto più complicate
di queste reti di telecomunicazioni.
Sono delle reti che sono nate circa
3,4 miliardi di anni fa:
sono delle reti metaboliche.
Sono delle reti che sfidano quella che
è la seconda legge della termodinamica:
cercano di mettere ordine nel caos,
un caos pazzesco
che c'è nelle nostre cellule,
che hanno miliardi,
centinaia di miliardi di molecole
che girano attorno - circa 100 miliardi,
se togliamo le molecole d'acqua.
E tutte queste interconnessioni
sono delle cose che devono essere messe
nella catena giusta, per potere dare
origine a quel fenomeno che è la vita, no?
Per poter crescere, moltiplicarsi, vivere.
Ebbene ci sono delle reti
che sono nate molto tempo dopo,
circa 600 milioni di anni fa
e che sono più complicate di queste.
Sono le reti che abbiamo
nel mondo degli animali,
quelle che portano l'informazione
al nostro cervello
e le reti, sopratutto,
che stanno nel nostro cervello.
Sono delle reti particolari
perché fanno emergere delle cose
che chiamiamo pensieri, sensazioni,
e quando io parlo, chiaramente parlo
con le vostre sensazioni,
le stimolo, magari,
parlo coi vostri pensieri
ma riesco a fare qualche cosa di più:
io riesco a entrare nel vostro cervello,
passare da questa rete di pensieri
ed entrare dentro,
nella vostra rete di neuroni.
Se io vi dico adesso
che voi indossate le scarpe
be', adesso voi sentite che avete i piedi,
non è vero?
E quindi sono entrato dentro di voi.
Cioè c'è questa correlazione
e nel cervello noi abbiamo circa
100 miliardi di neuroni,
più 100 miliardi di astrociti,
astrocita più astrocita meno,
e abbiamo 1.000 miliardi di connessioni.
Ecco sono questi volumi
che portano, in qualche modo,
anche a partire dalle cose molto semplici,
come è semplice un neurone, tutto sommato,
portano a questo emergere di pensieri,
a questa consapevolezza, alle emozioni.
E allora la domanda è:
ma io riesco a fare una rete
che in qualche modo abbia
anche queste caratteristiche?
Be', l'elettronica in questi
60 - 70 anni di evoluzione
ha fatto due cose incredibili:
una è ridurre enormemente quello che
è il componente di base, il transistor.
Siamo partiti nel 1947 con un transistor
che era lungo più o meno così
e già 20 anni dopo, questi transistor
erano diventati talmente piccoli
che si potevano mettere su una cosa
che si chiamava "piccolo chip",
un pezzetto di cose.
E abbiamo continuato a crescere, da una
parte aumentando sempre più transistor,
dall'altra riducendo
sempre più le dimensioni,
fino a quello che vedete
in questo diagramma
in cui il transistor è sceso
da questa nuvola azzurrina degli anni '70,
più grande di una nostra cellula,
fino a diventare sempre più piccolo,
più piccolo di un globulo rosso,
di uno spermatozoo,
più piccolo di un batterio,
più piccolo di un virus.
Nel 2002 i transistor sono diventati
più piccoli dei virus.
E l'altra magia è stata quella
di fare scendere enormemente i costi
per cui è diventato possibile produrre
sempre più transistor,
perché costavano sempre di meno.
E intorno al 2000, siamo arrivati a
produrre circa 100 miliardi di transistor,
e nel 2009, 2010 siamo arrivati
a produrre 100 miliardi di chip.
100 miliardi, questo numero torna, no?
Ma allora uno si chiede, dice:
"Ma va bene, io ho capito che posso
avere gli stessi numeri che abbiamo
nella testa, nel nostro cervello,
ma riusciamo a mettere
insieme queste cose?"
Vediamo che abbiamo dei transistor qui
che vanno a osservare i neuroni,
le reti di neuroni, e li misurano.
Quindi ci siamo, no?
Come dimensioni siamo proprio lì,
ma come complessità? Be', la complessità
che noi abbiamo in un centro,
tipo quello di un grande
datacenter di Google,
be', la vedete, è anche nei sotterranei,
non soltanto dei transistor.
Questa qui è la zona che serve
per rinfrescare, per portare
aria fredda, raffreddamento ai transistor.
Ma abbiamo una complessità
che è ancora maggiore
se andiamo a vedere al di fuori,
se andiamo a vedere
nelle nostre mani: i cellulari.
Questa è una figura di cellulari
che sono stati buttati via:
ogni giorno in Italia buttiamo via
86 mila cellulari, 86 mila!
Pensate se noi riuscissimo
a mettere insieme tutti questi cellulari
che tutti insieme hanno una capacità
di memoria, di memorizzazione,
di circa 200 milioni di GB,
che è una quantità più grande
dei grandi datacenter
che contengono le informazioni.
Ma è possibile mettere insieme
tutte queste cose?
Deve essere una cosa
estremamente complicata!
Come diavolo si potrebbe fare?
Be', se voi guardate queste immagini,
sono delle immagini di tordi
che stanno volando,
e vedete che creano delle architetture,
delle scenografie incredibili.
È come se ci fosse un tordo
più bravo degli altri che fa scenografie
e dice: "Guarda, tu ti sposti di là
e tu ti sposti di là".
E invece no,
sono delle regole semplicissime.
Il tordo cosa sta pensando
in questo momento?
"Cerchiamo di star dietro a quello che mi
sta davanti, così fatico meno a volare,
e cerchiamo di non sbattere
con quello che ho di fianco!"
Ecco! Queste semplici regole danno origine
a questi movimenti enormi.
Noi stiamo cominciando a capire
e a fare queste cose,
stiamo cominciando a capire
che una macchina
può circolare un po' da sola.
Il Centro di ricerche Fiat, qui a Trento,
sta provando a fare delle macchine
che effettivamente guidano da sole.
Ora queste macchine hanno
un loro mondo ed è autonomo,
ma ci sono altre macchine
che in contemporanea stanno guidando,
pensate quando ci saranno
tante di queste macchine:
ciascuna di queste fa i fatti suoi
in una certa misura,
ma deve anche capire che cosa le
altre stanno facendo e che cosa faranno.
Stiamo generando dei sistemi
autonomi, paralleli, complessi,
che ci portano proprio
in questa nuova dimensione,
che è una dimensione che, tutto sommato,
è naturale perché questa che vedete qui
rappresenta quella
che è la mia rete sociale,
presa da Linkedin.
Queste reti sociali sono delle reti
che cambiano nel tempo,
perché, se mi capita di parlare
con una persona con una certa frequenza,
è come se stabilissi un contatto molto
più forte tra me e lui o tra me e lei.
Ebbene queste cose qui cambiano
la mia rete e continua a variare,
giungono dei nuovi amici, ci sono amici
con cui non parlo da moltissimo tempo,
ci sono delle conoscenze occasionali.
Noi stiamo cercando di sperimentare
queste reti tra cervelli, tra teste,
proprio qui a Trento con lo Smart Campus
che c'è all'Università.
Utilizziamo le tecnologie
per vedere che cosa succede.
Quindi siamo già portati sul mondo
delle reti a livello di cervelli,
e riusciamo anche a fare delle cose
come quelle che vediamo qua:
questa è una fotografia scattata
nel salotto di casa in cui c'è Paolino,
il più piccolo dei miei figli,
anche se più alto di me oramai,
che mi diceva che,
io gli credevo, non lo so, comunque,
stava facendo un compito di latino.
E come lo stava facendo?
Aveva la tastiera bluetooth
collegata a un iPad,
che era collegato alla Apple TV,
a sua volta collegata col televisore,
in modo che lui scriveva
e vedeva le scritte di latino
comparire sul televisore.
Poi l'iPad era anche collegato
ad un gateway, a un modem ADSL,
che lo portava sul mondo Internet
per andare a cercare delle cose,
e poi aveva un iPhone di fianco
con cui, tramite FaceTime,
dialogava con i suoi amici.
Ecco io mi chiedo come facesse
Cicerone a fare un compito di Latino, no?
Di fronte a tutte queste cose,
è incredibile!
Ecco, però tutte queste reti qui
sono reti fatte in casa,
sono reti che non richiedono
una competenza incredibile.
Un ragazzino di 16 anni si mette lì,
crea la sua rete.
Questi ragazzini, nel tempo, diventeranno,
guariranno, diventeranno grandi, no?
E saranno loro il nostro futuro
e continueranno a fare queste reti,
saranno reti fatte in casa
che andranno per tutto il mondo.
Veramente siamo tornati
al tempo di quando ero io ragazzino.
È una cosa fantastica, tecnologica,
tutto sommato è ancora magia.
[Applausi]